trying to get stuff done man what's the
problem I hope like I needs to be darker
let's say we just try to get this color
like solid well then we she just
spray-painted so many more hours until
we hit the shoot twelve yeah who's that
rustling around in the dark tomorrow we
have to finish painting this shield
hopefully I want to sleep here you never
know final details on this guy or to
paint the blade instead of just painting
it like straight silver which would come
out looking kind of silly should do is
you get a little bit of painters a
really common technique take almost all
of it off go back and forth like this is
just going to give that really like
brushed one metal of texture we're going
to thunder studios today to film a
little tale about to trick shatters
supposed to be a hospital room just a
hot like a patient's room
yeah well red in my opinion just stop
oh yeah my business making a hospital
come on miss Partridge let's go I guess
we don't actually like have an IV stamps
we're gonna use this East End shooting
it shouldn't take very long sure it's
all gonna be in the rehearsal at night
he uses a similar bounce only it is
electrified and called the light hey
what are you doing library
I am wrangling a cable as far as what
it's doing a scene record we have to
fork a zip lights which I've always been
a big fan of wood that RCTV down kicking
through that window then for a fill
we're going to be using our 1k here
normally I'd have some sort of bounce
board but we're gonna have a lot of
people kind of coming through here so
I'm trying to keep things as minimal as
possible we're catching a hot spot in
frame which really makes it not seem
like it's the Sun and also to get more
output to where we need it we're gonna
bring it over so it's more angled on the
bed and hopefully that'll take the hot
spot that was making me worried away the
crops never stops
let's plug that into one of the circuits
that isn't being used there we go what
type of late are you adding in why a
hard source to kind of be the point of
the Sun the rest of its kind of just
ambience said I would change a few
things if I had everything perfect in
the world but it's a flawed world Jake
yeah I have now gone through a variety
of costumes for you guys and I feel like
and I've told you exactly what I want
yeah Sam go go Jake once what is that
all right well the white shirt with the
wrap arounds I like these glasses so
much I know what they do so you just
goofy everyone okay I know but wrap
around like this doesn't say anything
yeah it does and the white t-shirt with
the shark come on just funny the giant
shark is ruled to see you all right
let's grab the camera and everyone and
the GoPros all right you're what I'll do
it
well I got a repost this cool corridor
Instagram picture because so cool
people need to see it twice which one
the corridor digital Instagram at
corridor digital or my personal line
spam at Nico dig you can follow me if
you want to I mean I post pretty cool
pictures I feel like it's like riding on
me so I just got to make sure we get
this done so if I'm an I
apologize but it might happen oh that
son of a did in if this shows
delay then Soviet